MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
So we're going to continue
the discussion that
makes a case against ether when
discussing stellar aberration.
So the problem we
have in mind here
is the ones where we
use a telescope to look
at a distant star.
When we do this,
the fact of ether
might change the way we have
to orient our telescope.
Let's have a look at this.
So we are in a situation
that our hypothesis
is that the ether exists.
This carries-- is the medium
in which light travels.
But it's dragged with earth.
So this is our case number one.
In that situation, the
telescope looks at the star.
The light of the star enters
our telescope at the top
and then tries to
go to the bottom.
Because the medium in
which the light travels
and the telescope move with
the same velocity-- remember,
the ether is dragged
with the earth--
the light appears to go
straight down the telescope.
Without the--
[INAUDIBLE] case 2,
without the ether being
dragged or even exist,
we actually do have to
slightly tilt our telescope.
Why?
Because after the light hits
the top of our telescope,
the telescope keeps
moving because it's
in a different reference frame.
And therefore, we have to
have this slight tilting.
The value of the tilt
is equal to velocity
of the Earth over C.
This is a well-known effect in
astrophysics and, by the way,
was already studied way earlier
by James Bradley in the 1720s.
He actually developed the--
not really supported
theory of light
where he was talking about
particle nature of light.
So his idea was very
similar to case 2,
that the Earth is moving
in a different reference
frame with respect to
the star and the sun,
moving around the sun.
And therefore, the
tilting angle needs
to be the tangent of
the tilting and needs
to be equal to the distance
of Earth to the Sun.
And the distance is [INAUDIBLE]
this angle is very, very small
because the nearest star
[INAUDIBLE] to Earth
is about four light years away.
So with this now, we can again
do our ether versus particle
nature model comparison.
So in our first discussion,
we concluded clearly
that the wave and ether
hypothesis dominates or wins.
But now we have studied at
least two further experiments.
So, again, I invite you
to stop here and think
about how stellar aberration
and Michelson-Morley would
be answers to the particle
model or wave model [INAUDIBLE]
explanation.
As a thought experiment,
the Fizeau and Airy
experiment that we haven't
and did not discuss this here.
All right.
So for stellar aberration,
the particle model actually
seems to work, as it
was proposed apparently
to solve this very problem.
And the Michelson-Morey
experiment
also is consistent with
the particle model.
So now we're in this dilemma
that some experiments
or experimental
evidence for particle
ether nature and some for
the particle nature of light.
So the question of how do we get
out of the dilemma-- and we'll
discuss this in [INAUDIBLE]
the next section.